it's my pleasure to introduce today's
speaker but before I do that I want to
acknowledge this is our final pftt for
the year and it's the Roenick desai
memorial talk Roenick was a member of
the mba class of 2010 and we're joined
today by several of his classmates and
friends as our special guests my neck
was a remarkable and accomplished
individual and as a student leader of
the view from the top series he was
passionate about exploring how prominent
leaders who run some of the world's most
influential enterprises can truly impact
the lives of millions he recognized that
each of these leaders have their own
personal story their own values and
their own ideas about how to make change
happen
he's desire to learn from these
individuals was motivated by a
commitment to reflecting on his own
personal leadership story he aimed to
leave a positive and significant mark on
the world but he wanted to do so in a
way that was consistent with his values
to this end his talent and ambition was
always complemented by his extraordinary
warm spirit and his gracious good humor
after Ronix untimely death his
classmates asked if we could dedicate
one talk each year in his memory this
year we thought it was only appropriate
to invite Ken Chenault
to give this special talk as Roenick
interviewed Ken when he was last here in
2010 in the spirit of today's talk I
encourage you to reflect not only on our
speaker and the company that he runs but
what has experience and the experience
of all of the speakers in our series can
teach you about your own role and
potential as a leader I hope and I think
Roenick would also hope that this
reflection helps you set your sights a
little farther challenge yourself a
little bit harder and to challenge and
to think more a bit more deeply about
what it means to pursue a life of
meaning and impact while staying true to
yourself and the things that you value
as a tribute to Roenick before we begin
please join me in a moment of silence
thank you so now I would like to welcome
and introduce tensional the chairman and
CEO of American Express ken has been an
American American Express for more than
30 years having joined the company in
its strategic planning group in 1981
before this he worked as an associate at
Roger and Wells after graduating from
Harvard Law School and worked as a
consultant at Bain & Company he was
promoted to president and CEO at
American Express in 1997 and was named
CEO in 2001 American Express or Amex
founded in 1850 is a fortune 100
diversified financial services company
with more than thirty billion in revenue
it's one of the 30 companies that make
up the Dow Jones Industrial Average and
is best known for its credit card charge
card and traveler's check business in
indeed of Amex accounts for roughly
twenty four percent of the total dollar
volume of credit card transactions in
the United States much of their success
stems not from an individual product
however but for their long-standing
prowess in consumer marketing that I'm
sure you're well aware of membership has
its privileges don't leave home without
it these are just a couple of tag lines
that have really entered the American
cultural lexicon and as a result
American Express is truly one of the
best-known brands in the world today and
has consistently ranked among the
world's top 25 most valuable brands
another reason the brand is so valuable
is Amex is commitment and reputation for
customer service in 2012 JD Power ranked
Amex highest for customer satisfaction
among card issuers for the sixth
straight year fortune recently listed as
one of the 15 most admired companies in
the world Ken Chenault and his team have
certainly played a critical role in
building and maintaining a strong brand
when Ken was here in 2010 he talked
about leading his 65,000 employees
through the many challenges the
company's experienced during his time as
CEO saying clearly my tenure has been
one of confronting some of the most
challenging crises that we've seen in
the last 10 years I take my model from
Napoleon make sure people are grounded
in reality and give them strategies to
be hopeful Ken's made an impact well
beyond Amex
currently co-chair of the Business
Roundtable he serves on the board of IBM
is a member of the Council of Foreign
Relations and it received many business
and civic awards Avenue magazine named
him one of 50 living pioneers in the
African African American community
having been only the third African
American to run a fortune 500 company
today andrew baldwin one of our
second-year student leaders from the
view from the top team is going to
interview ken and so please join me
today and well put in welcoming
tensional to Stanford GSB
okay all right so thank you very much
for coming today when I found out that I
was going to get the chance to interview
you I was thrilled and it took me back
to the first time that I interacted with
American Express the brand I would just
graduate from college I was moving from
Indiana to New York and when I got to
New York I found out that New York's a
little more expensive than I thought
so is that any responsible 22 year old I
applied for my first credit card it was
a visa and they gave me I was the first
mister that was the first mistake the
only mistake I've made sense and they
gave me a credit limit of $1,500
and I told a friend this story he said
you're an idiot for not being an
American Express so the next day I
applied for American Express an American
Express gave me a credit limit of 25
thousand dollars when I look back I can
only think that you personally thought
that I was 16 times more valuable than
Visa - so hopefully I can repay some of
that appreciation through this talk
thank you
I want to start out the interview with a
very similar to question 2 what Roenick
asked during his 2010 interview you've
led Amex through a pretty incredible
time right after you joined as CEO right
after he became CEO 9/11 occurred and
then you also were the head of a
financial services company during the
worst financial downturn in 80 years and
kept your job which is no small feat can
you walk us through the one or two days
that were the biggest tests or the
largest challenges certainly first just
let me say it's it's a real honor to be
here and obviously I remember Roenick
very vividly and was just impressed with
both his authenticity and his humility
so it means a lot for me to be here we
really appreciate it so let me just say
that obviously 9/11 and the financial
crisis were absolutely incredible I
would say the most horrible obviously
was 9/11
from from a emotional standpoint because
we lost 11 employees and the loss of
human life is always a tragedy what was
most important there was to rally the
organization to understand both the
reasons why they should be hopeful but
also dealing with the reality that the
travel industry was in total disarray
spending on our credit cards had dropped
dramatically and what I recognized was
that we had to transform the company in
a relatively short period of time and
that leads me to one of I think the real
challenges from a leadership standpoint
is how to be decisive and compassionate
so within 60 days of 9/11 I decided that
we had to substantially change our cost
structure which meant that we were going
to have to layoff employees and many
people in my top executive team said
this is not the time to do it and from
an emotional standpoint they were
absolutely right the concern that I had
was that the future of the company was
at stake
and I said we have to do this in a
compassionate way with our employees but
we have to do it and what I believe very
strongly that one of the things you've
got to do in leadership is you need to
tell people both the truth and you don't
talk down to people and you explain to
people the reasons why and I'll cut to
the chase just to simplify so we can
also talk about the financial crisis is
what I explained to people were the
reasons why what was happening to the
company and at that time we always do a
employee survey and a third of our
incentive compensation is really based
on
the satisfaction and engagement of our
employees because we really do believe
in the surface service profit chain and
people said Ken if you're gonna lay off
basically 12% of the workforce the last
thing you want to do is to do a survey
on it and I said not only are we gonna
survey the employees but when a survey
the people that we laid off because from
a leadership standpoint everyone has to
be held accountable and I think
partially because of the times that we
were in with 911 but also the leadership
and the way that was done we received
the highest employee survey scores that
we had in years so that was very much a
turning point for the company and then
frankly one of the most exciting things
for me was over the last five to ten
years is in fact to see some of those
employees come back to the company
because of the growth of the company and
what was happening the financial crisis
was very different on one level it
didn't have the the emotion of the loss
of human life but you really felt that
you were falling off the cliff and in a
crisis what I think is very very
important and where it really hit me was
when Congress voted against tarp and I
vividly remember my son is now a junior
in college calling me and saying dad
everyone says that the company's going
down and you're gonna be fired and I
said Kevin it's not going to be that bad
don't worry about it
but the reality is that represented the
fear because to me when messages
permeate the playground you know this is
really serious that there are real
problems and for us where we were
impacted is we were very reliant on the
wholesale funding model so we did not
take deposits and so literally over a
weekend and this goes to the power
of a brand I said we've got to get into
the deposit business and both inside and
outside the company people said you know
given what's going on with financial
services companies and the environment
there is no way you're gonna get this up
and running the only way we could do it
was in fact to work with third parties
so we in fact work with other financial
services companies to basically sell our
deposit products and I then put together
a mantra for the company because I
wanted to have all 60,000 plus employees
focused on what we needed to do when it
was really simple stay liquid stay
profitable and then the hope port was
selectively invest in growth so even in
the most challenging times I wanted to
reinforce that we were not gonna take
our eye off the ball of really being
focused on growth but staying liquid was
critical and fortunately within around
30 days we'd raised around eight billion
in deposits we now have over forty
billion in deposits that gave me a lot
of hope and gave the organization and
the company a lot of hope because I said
why would people be putting money in
with us if they thought we were going
out of business number one number two we
were able to stay profitable that was
critical third was what I also looked at
as far as customer health was how many
customers traded down from our more
expensive products to less priced
products and the reality is almost zero
and we had hardly anyone who left the
franchise that gave me a lot of
confidence then the third thing that we
were able to do back to the mantra is we
were very clear to people in the company
where we were investing and that allowed
us to come out of the crisis frankly
really roaring so the momentum of the
company was very very strong and my
experience frankly over 30 years is what
you see what
companies is it really is what happens
during a crisis is how two companies act
how balanced they are the majority of
companies in fact hunker in the bunker
don't really have a broader perspective
don't focus on growth and then generally
two to three years after a crisis you
start to see this demarcation that's
caused and that's exactly what happened
for us fortunately we were on the
positive side back and speaking of a
lighter note over those thirty years and
even maybe more specifically over the
last 12 a CEO is there one day that you
look to and you're like man that is the
day why that's the reason why I do this
this is a great day this is kind of what
gets me excited and and just passionate
about the business is there one day
you'll look back to I would say
literally there fortunately a hundreds
of days because my view and business is
if if you're not having fun it's not
worth it but I'll give you one example
that again was a tragedy but gave me a
lot of pride is I think everyone
certainly remembers the tsunami and
you've got the problem a second mistake
that's right and and and and the reality
was that our employees around the world
with literally no instructions from top
management did incredible things to
serve people and that just gave me
incredible pride because when people
feel empowered to make a difference and
literally make up policies on their own
but it was because they really believed
in the service mission and the service
ethic of the company that's where I felt
great but fortunately I have literally
hundreds of examples like that that make
me feel great about being at the game
you're making my transitions really easy
to the next question so the next
question is actually about customer
service when I think about American
Express I think it's the gold standard
of service and
in fact you've taken a really boring
piece of plastic and turned it into a
club that has a cult following this room
is full of aspiring entrepreneurs or
managers who want to build equally great
brands equally great service cultures
how did American Express do it and what
would you what knowledge or advice would
you provide to them yeah here's what I
think is very very important and
building a brand is if you think about
what are the attributes of the most
powerful brands brands are really about
bringing a rational and emotional
connection because the best brands have
a personal engagement and the best
brands and the brands in a really long
term are those brands that in fact have
what I call a higher purpose that it's
more than just selling a product that
you're changing people's lives you're
impacting people's lives you're allowing
people to have fun and when you have a
brand that combines that rational value
proposition with a emotional connection
it's really powerful what people forget
because the card has been so successful
is the company started off as a freight
forwarding company and what's critical
is the reinvention of the company over
163 years
one was that commitment to service was
really critical the point I make about
our travel is check business is that it
had no income requirement anyone could
get it it was used all over the world
that helped build the brand allowing us
to offer a card right now part of what I
do particularly with the partnerships
that we have with a number of digital
companies I say the form factor is
irrelevant
the reality is think about the card as a
platform to deliver service so what's
important is that you've got to
understand to create a brand you need a
core mission
and for us we want to be the most
respected service brand trust of the
brand is very critical service is very
critical security is very critical and
then what you've got to do is constantly
innovate because if you want to be a
leading brand
you've got to innovate in the
marketplace all the time and what I
would also emphasize with respect to
service is what I found is and I say
this publicly and certainly I'm very
competitive I want to win so I don't
foolishly give out secrets but the
reality is that most companies don't
want to make a commitment to service one
is because it's a long term investment
two is they don't have the right metrics
in place to know they're getting the
returns we in fact know what service
interactions will generate levels of
spending we know what will drive
retention and loyalty of our customers
and one of the things that we did in our
service despite the fact that for years
we had great service around ten years
ago we said we're gonna revamp it we're
gonna reinvent the way we do service we
think people are too robotic we think if
there were to rule focused and we want
to empower the people who are serving
our customers where that's online or
offline and we literally changed
fundamental aspects of our service and
that leads to a very important point
which I believe in strongly is you
always want to create the company that
will put yourself out of business that's
the way you constantly need to think and
if you believe that you're successful
and you get arrogant about that success
that success becomes a rut specifically
on one service point I love your
customers the customer service
representatives so much so that
we confide in them more than my own
parents sometimes right and they are
consistently and always friendly what
what's the secret training or
recruitment process that you use to
always have that consistency because I
actually view that as a pretty big
competitive advantage
it's a big advantage you know here's
here's the simple answer to that and it
took us a while to get there
his attitude makes a difference is
actually hire people who like the serve
people that is a stunning insight I mean
give me a break
and so you in fact can interview people
you can test people you can assess
people who really do have the attributes
and have the desire to serve and really
enjoy it
there are some people in fact when I
talk to even senior people and I
interview them and I talk about service
as a higher purpose I get some people
say hey that's not a purpose for me it's
not a higher purpose for me
that's fine then I don't want to hire
you because at the end of the day you've
really got to believe in what the core
mission is but attitude really does make
a difference and you can interview you
can assess for it
you can empower people but sometimes
companies get so bogged down in policies
and rules that for us as terrific as we
were historically as a service company
we did not explicitly enough focus on
the attitude of people that we were
hiring and now over the last 20 years
our retention rates our customer SATs
cores are off the graph and our service
levels are really strong because we have
people who really enjoy serving people
and not everyone does a couple weeks ago
Jack Dorsey was on the stage here and he
was talking about kind of the shift in
almost commerce and payments and
absolutely that everything
from how we buy where we buy what we use
to buy is going change and he talked
about squares you wallet how does a
company that's been around for a hundred
and sixty three years kind of fit in
with this model and are we are we going
to stop carrying credit cards we could
and frankly I don't care because it's
really what's behind the card so Jack
actually talked to before he started
square we work with square they acquire
a lot of merchants for us what I think
is absolutely terrific is that Jack is
empowering small merchants and really
helping small business we are the
largest provider to small business so
the synergy is really strong what I
think it's important and the way you
change is I believe Commerce is changing
dramatically and the way I talk about
our company now is that part of our
objective is bringing buyers and sellers
together and the advantage that we have
and this is an advantage that Jack
recognizes and I give him a lot of
credit for his Square is built off an
existing payments infrastructure that's
a real advantage so he has been
innovative what he hasn't done is to say
I got to change everything that's one of
the reasons why I like the mobile app
uber because they're building off an
existing platform and they're innovating
and changing the payments experience so
for us what we've said is we have a
major major advantage in that we are the
most integrated payments platform of
anyone so we acquire merchants we
process merchant transactions we are an
issuer and we authorize transactions all
over the world there is no other card
company no one in payments who has a
fully integrated payments model we're
the only one now what that does is we
talk about a closed loop and that means
we have
formation on the in user customer and
the merchant and the ability to do
modeling and algorithms with that data
is going to give us frankly an even
bigger advantage going forward than in
the past because the convergence of
online offline unleashes the assets and
capabilities that we have in the
platform so part of what we started to
do almost a decade ago was to say we
really are going to embrace the digital
transformation and what we've done is
with existing people in the company
people have really been able to change
those who weren't are no longer with the
company because the reality is that they
had to keep up with the change what I've
also done is bring in people from
outside the company and have a mix and
match so we promote probably 60 to 65%
of our people from within but we also
bring in people from the outside and
I'll give you one way that I dramatize
this to our board is I had a voiceover
of someone talking about what the brand
meant to them
and they talked about Amex and trust
security service reinvention and then as
you pan down you saw the nose ear ring
in the earrings and the tattoos and I
said welcome to the new American Express
because the point is this reinvention is
critical so I think that the assets are
there the partnerships I'll just mention
one that I'm excited about
with Twitter where we're using our
closed-loop platform where you can do
tweet to buy we're the only ones that
can do that with Twitter so when it was
announced all these folks were calling
up Twitter and saying we would like to
do the same thing and Twitter respond
the problem is Amex is the only one has
the platform
so clearly there'll be people and
there's a lot going on there's more
innovation going on right now in
commerce and payments than almost
anyplace else but we're not standing
still it's stayin with the theme of
innovation
I want to pivot to policy right you're
on the President's Council for jobs and
in competitiveness I was it's no longer
works but I was and it probably were to
treat the President or the United States
as one of your customers who's over
levered hypothetically what advice would
you give on kind of current deficit
levels how to manage you know increasing
debt levels over time
so obviously with the proper service
training I do it in a very polite but
forceful way but in all seriousness I
think what is most important and from my
experience on the jobs Council I went in
questioning how much of a difference
could be made in creating jobs I
actually believe that the jobs issue is
a solvable issue we did a lot of work
identifying different industry areas
where we can drive growth putting
together both short and long term
strategies obviously you get down to
politics and getting that through on
both sides of the house but the reality
is that I think there are several things
that need to be done one is we do have
to promulgate some pro-growth policies
when I look at the infrastructure in the
u.s. there are major improvements that
have to be made that can help stimulate
job growth but also can make us a more
productive and
Pettit --iv economy secondly we have to
deal with entitlements that's just the
reality and so back to your analogy of
someone who is having credit problems
you got to sit down and you got to say
here's the spending that has to stop but
thirdly I think what's very important is
that tax reform in a comprehensive way
both personal and corporate we've got to
really bring about a set of fundamental
changes and I think that what is
required is not just an issue of being
focused on what the president the Senate
and the house does I think we need to
put more public pressure on and I look
at this frankly as almost like a social
movement that your generation the next
generation your lives are in jeopardy if
you really felt that on a social issue I
think you would have a much different
attitude and approach and I think we
need a far more engaged electorate that
is going to put real pressure because
the existing approach is not driving
change fast enough that's great feedback
and from what I understand about
American Express this culture you have a
culture of constructive confrontation
and transparency and here at the GSB we
have a euphemism that feedbacks a gift
could you share with us a story when you
had to give or receive one of these
gifts that's not so pleasant sure sure
I I would say probably halfway
three-quarters through my career things
were going really well I thought I was
getting terrific feedback which in
general I was and we had this process
where you got feedback and there were
always ten things that you did really
well and then ten things that you needed
to improve and it didn't matter who you
were you always had ten things that you
needed to improve because if you was no
matter what your station you should
always focus on being a good leader so
it was always depressing particularly if
you're really focused on saying I want
to be the best to confront that there
are things you got to focus on then we
started to say well what are one or two
things that you need to focus on in an
our feedback process you had to talk to
your team about here are the things who
are the things that are positive here
are the things that are negative and so
one thing that came out with me is that
I didn't listen well and I actually
thought geez I I am respectful for
people I sit in meetings I listen to
people and the feedback I got was can
you know your mind's always racing and
if you don't think someone is saying
something that's really smart you
literally will just turn off you won't
frown but we know that you are not there
that's not what's going on here between
not at all not at all
and that really that really hit me I
mean I didn't fully realize I was doing
it and didn't really realize not just
the impact that was having on the person
that I was talking to but obviously the
impact that had in the entire room
because at that time I wasn't president
but I was a pretty senior person and you
know almost the phrase was you know this
is one of Ken's own outs and he's
thinking about something else and one of
the things that I clearly learned from
that feedback was that I was missing out
it doesn't mean that every time someone
was talking to me I thought
they were saying something that was
really terrific I would certainly let
them know I don't think that's a great
idea here are the reasons why but I was
actively engaged and you've got to have
that two-way street and if you listen
some more those ideas can come out so
the the ability to be what I call an
active listener can actually empower
that person who you're talking to that
was a real learning for me was
incredibly helpful and it took several
years before I got the recognition that
I was an active listener now people say
boy ken is a really good listener
someone has been in the company a long
time I said well let me tell you back
ken 10 or 15 years ago he wasn't such a
great listener
so that's but I think for anyone one of
the things that I try to do really every
year is think about two or three areas
that I want to improve going forward in
my own leadership so I'm going to lean
in for this next question I know that
you are very close friends with Sheryl
Sandberg
and a big fan of her philosophy lean in
but the facts are and kind of
unfortunately so that inequalities still
exist you're one of six African American
CEOs they're only twenty female fortune
500 CEOs why is the past so difficult
for African Americans females and other
minorities at very senior levels within
corporate America yeah I think there are
several reasons I mean I think clearly
what you can't deny is that bias and
Prejudice still exists and the legacy of
bias and Prejudice has a major impact
that just doesn't go away and you know I
always go back if I could rewrite
history
yeah and say in just pick an era in the
1920s there was full equal opportunity
despite all that happened historically
I think we would be so far ahead but
that didn't happen and so I think you've
got to deal with that issue
I think second is and this is part of
what Cheryl is talking about we can all
analyze the reasons why we can't get
ahead and we should be very focused on
that and we should all feel a collective
responsibility to change that but one of
the points when I was growing up that my
father emphasized with me was focus on
what you can what you can control and
the only thing you can control is your
performance there's several ways you can
look at that he was not saying that to
limit me what he was saying was that
opens up a range of opportunities and
from a accountability standpoint don't
in fact run away from that problem or
challenge or a barrier figure out a way
to jump over it and so what Cheryl is
certainly not saying is that there are
not a set of major issues and big issues
and institutional issues that women have
to deal with but that women clearly can
take increasing ownership for what they
need to do that a support structure is
very helpful because we all need a
support structure and that's important
and that we got to take it very
personally I think at the end of the day
what's most important is there's a
surprising phenomenon that happens and
it's not really surprising when you get
people in positions who look different
and are different all of a sudden
several years later you get more people
who look like them and so the
representation
issue is a big issue is an important
issue and it is at some point and this
is where I go to just business metrics
if someone is simply saying each year
can I'm gonna grow this business is
really gonna do well here are my
strategies and each year nothing happens
that's a problem so if there is a real
commitment and a real focus then there
need to be measures and there needs to
be accountability so that those things
happen and I think that a business
mentality around that they can bring
about some very important social change
I'd love to open it up to questions from
the audience and right before I do I
just want to say one quote that I found
particularly inspiring from you
in the 2008 commencement address at
Howard University you said it's a
responsibility to the larger
african-american community to face
prejudice and to make progress to face
history and to make history and that was
something that I really enjoyed and
reading and was inspired by so I just
wanted to share that feedback and a
public setting but thank you love to
open up the audience to Q&A and what the
tough questions roll good
someone in the front here hi my name is
Nikki jour de niro and I'm a second year
MBA student here we're really glad that
you were able to join us today so of a
two-part question related to sort of
those very tough decisions that you were
talking about you know going into the
deposits business etc one when you make
those tough decisions would you say it's
more of a intuition gut feeling that you
have or more consensus driven from the
people and you're really senior advisors
and the second part of that is it is
more gut and what you think is the right
decision then what is your process for
bringing people on board and really
rallying people behind really tough
decisions it's a good question I I think
one what I'm a firm believer in is that
you have to apply what I call
situational leadership that you can't
just follow one style sometimes you have
to have a directive style sometimes you
have to have a consensus building style
there have to be some attributes from a
leadership standpoint one of those that
I talk a lot about is integrity because
that's the only way you're gonna build
trust and that's for me the consistency
of words and actions but in some cases I
have relied on my gut but backed up with
some analysis I think it's very very
rare sometimes on creative issues I look
at a piece of advertising and you sort
of know this is it and you can't totally
explain why but in a lot of situations I
think you can analyze and you should
but then judgment is really important
but judgment should be based on what's
the criteria that you're using to make
that judgement what are the values that
you're applying to make that judgment
so what I don't believe in is making
blind judgments I think you always need
to have some criteria and you always
need to have that balance by what values
are important from a consensus
standpoint there are some issues that I
know where I want to go but I know that
I've got to get everyone involved and
I'll give you one example when I took
over a CEO I said I want to change
actually some of the core attributes of
our culture I didn't think we were
focused explicitly enough on winning in
the marketplace I didn't think we
engaged enough in constructive
confrontation so I literally put here
the values I'd like for the company on a
piece of paper for myself and then I
said a fact what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do sessions all around the world
and I want teams so to come up with the
values and I'd say very honestly I don't
know what I would have done if the
values hadn't pretty much matched what I
had on the sheet of paper but
fortunately they did the benefit of that
was the buy-in was almost instant
because people knew it was a consensus
driven process it wasn't me mandating
that so I think there's certain issues
where you mandate I'll give you an
example where from a the standpoint of
having to decide was and this goes back
to 9/11 I decided that we were going to
return to our headquarters the majority
of the organization would have voted
against it for very understandable
reasons I thought it was important for
us to go back explain the reasons why
and it was accepted so there's some
things that you can't do by consensus
and that was more of a gut belief
feeling but it was based on a set of
values beliefs of why we should go back
so I think you want to make sure that
you adapt your leadership style to the
situation which means you've got to
assess in the lingo that we use at our
company
you've got to assess the readiness of
your group to accept certain leadership
so there's some situations where you
know you've got to be very directive
there are other situations where you're
gonna be more consensus driven hi my
name is gender table and I'm a happy
Amex customer good thanks for sharing
your thoughts my question is regarding
the new markets that are coming up now
are emerging so for example there are
2.5 billion people who don't have access
to banking is Amex planning to do
something in that area and if you are
what challenges do you see given the in
a lack of brand in those countries and
the u.s. relations with those countries
so here's here's what I think it's
interesting one is I think a number of
the emerging developing markets
obviously represent tremendous growth
opportunities what we've seen from a
brand standpoint whether it's China
India a range of markets that our brand
doesn't limit us and people find that
strange but I think one of the reasons
why our brand is viewed as a more open
brand is because of the heritage of the
travel business that we really cut
across borders and so people don't look
at us as a US only company alone really
has not hurt us so even in a place like
Russia the brand is really powerful but
I think the key part of your question is
how do we open the brand so back to the
importance of this convergence of
online/offline the implication of that
of what I've said to our people is scale
has been redefined so it's not enough to
say well we got a hundred million
cards when Facebook has a billion
customers Google has 1.7 billion
customers and the fact that to your
point there are many people that don't
have access to credit and debit products
so we're very focused on us so I'll talk
to you about two things we're doing one
is we've come out with what's called a
reloadable prepaid card which a
reloadable prepaid card is you deposit
money into the card the reality is that
this was first launched in the US but we
also are going to be launching in a
number of markets around the world and
in the US alone there are thirty four
billion households that are unbanked or
underbanked so that means if you don't
have a checking account you pay 800 to a
thousand dollars to in fact have access
to your own money alright so if you want
to cash your paycheck you pay to cash
your paycheck you want to send money to
someone someone in LA from here it could
cost you ten or eleven dollars to send
80 bucks so the reality is that there is
a tremendous need so we came out with a
product that is in fact on a digital
platform and it is you can operate it
totally on mobile and as you know the
penetration of smartphones is as high or
higher in non affluent sectors and it is
affluent sectors because they can't
afford a laptop they can't afford
broadband services so this is a product
that people initially said to me well
Amex you know you've got these high-end
cards how can you offer this product and
I said back to the future the reality is
the travellers cheque business freight
forwarding business was that a
prestigious business that in fact
enhanced the brand because we were
focused on service the question is
creating the right value proposition
with the right economic
to that segment we think this is going
to be a very exciting product since we
launched it in October 85% of the
customers coming in are new the
franchise almost 50% are under 35 so we
have a lot of hope there another thing
we're doing in China is we have done a
joint venture with a company called
LeAnn LeAnn you've heard of mobile
top-up see you go and you want to top up
your minutes on your phone in China you
go to a kiosk what we're doing is off of
a mobile phone you'll have the access to
do p2p were in three provinces now we're
expanding this company has 300 million
customers so I wouldn't mind getting a
nice percentage and penetration of that
customer base so what's important is
that we have redefined the scale and
then we've said there are also
opportunities to bring in to bring
buyers and sellers together around the
world why because we have a global
authorization system where literally we
can basically decide every single
transaction what that credit limit is
going to be instantaneously well if you
think about a global marketplace and the
ability cross-border for goods and
services that presents a tremendous
opportunity so the traditional card
business is changing dramatically we're
not walking away from that business but
we're expanding dramatically into other
areas and if we don't dramatically grow
in those markets we're not gonna be a
growth company so we have a strong focus
there I think we have time for one more
question from the audience or someone
here right in front Andy
is it on oh is it on okay
one of the benefits of defining yourself
in terms of a higher purpose is that it
doesn't confine you to a particular
product or service or category how far
do you think you can and how far do you
want to push the AMEX brand do you think
there will come a time where our
relationship with MX occurs in something
that's completely removed from financial
transactions or financial services yeah
you know already if you think about it
you're a relationship with us is I think
more than just a financial transaction
we are and always have been far more
involved as a lifestyle product so when
people ask me about competition I'm
competing with almost every lifestyle
provider in the traditional business
because if I'm reduced to facilitating a
payment that doesn't make me special at
all so I think that where you're gonna
see us spread out more is in commerce so
the things we've done with Twitter and
Facebook where you can take what we call
our spin graph and connect it to the
interests and preferences of Facebook
customer and connect them is pretty
powerful and we can do that with a
closed loop so I think that certainly
we're going to spread out more in
commerce Travel gives us a tremendous
opportunity of what we're doing from a
lifestyle standpoint the last thing I
want right where we will have a problem
is if we're positioned more and more
it's just a financial services company
what has helped us tremendously from a
brand standpoint is the customer looks
at us more as a service company than a
financial services company I want to
make sure I keep that demarcation
so we'll do one last question because we
skipped you will repeat it if you just
say yeah I think what's very very
important is one which I feel strongly
is I think it's a mistake and a number
of people do it is they get their person
confused with a job they hold I don't
get I try not to get that confused
I like being CEO but that's not where
I'd take my self-worth from the fact
that I'm CEO one of things that I do in
a very very aggressive way is I seek out
feedback and input both inside and
outside the company is really to talk to
people who have very different
perspectives from mine and to try to
find out and to build a network both
inside and outside the company
that will talk to me because the reality
is doesn't matter who you are people
will be well-meaning and they'll say I
don't really want to talk to Ken about
this I just don't want to worry him well
the reality is sometimes when that's
done I'm missing a big issue that can
impact the company and that's not
helpful
it's my job then to make sure that I'm
very aggressive from an outreach
standpoint and so I really am throughout
the company through hierarchy people who
know know me know that if you report
directly into
it's not that I'm gonna be checking on
you with other people but I'm gonna call
people five or ten levels down in the
company I'm gonna have meetings with
people it's not gonna be based on title
it's based on learning about what the
issues are what the problems are and
then outside what I want to ask people
is what do you think we're doing wrong
what do you think we need to do better
what are the issues and that goes back
to the constructive confrontation so you
really want to create a climate where
you're being pushed and in fact I don't
think I'm really getting the true word
unless I go through periods where I'm
feeling uncomfortable and I think that's
a good state for people to be and
periodically not permanently but
periodically uncomfortable because that
is a leveler and that's important
particularly when you're CEO to be in
those situations where you can be in a
more level place in closing we always
ask our view from the top speakers the
same question that we all have to answer
on the GSB application what matters to
most and why well things change over
time
what I would say is what matters to me
most is really my wife and my two sons
from a public policy standpoint what
matters to me most is income inequality
and third for me personally what matters
to be most is maintaining my integrity
and authenticity thank you very much
you